c'était mon métier je vous la corde ça
saute pas aux yeux ça a duré 15 ans et
au bout de ses 15 ans où j'en étais je
vais vous laisser découvrir par vous
même un extrait de mon dernier combat à
chanter à du monde qui m'oppose à à une
russe je suis en bleu la russe est en
rouge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà où j'en étais au sommet de ma
performance
donc je suis championne du monde est ce
ce titre n'est pas le premier c'est le
cinquième alors au delà de vos goûts
vous appelez les applaudissements c'est
donc je suis le plus fier c'est d'être
ici debout devant vous ma plus belle
victoire c'est d'avoir su être
performante en me respectant atteindre
la performance véritable c'est ce que je
vous propose d'explorer je veux
m'appuyer sur mon expérience de la boxe
veut sinapi et son expérience de vie
pour partager avec vous ce que j'ai
compris de cette notion de performance
ce que j'ai compris aussi de cette quête
de performance qui parfois s'avère
dangereuse et qui conduit elle même à la
défaillance
j'ai commencé à boxer et a4 vers 13 ans
il ya 14 ans j'ai disputé mon premier
championnat de france gt une fille
plutôt timide réservé je n'osais pas
niveau de confiance en moi c'était
proche de zéro et je remporte ce premier
championnat de france à mon grand
étonnement
à partir de là il ya une chemin qui se
déroule devant moi un chemin de deux
performances jalonné par des titres de
championne de france des titres de
championne d'europe et puis me voilà au
bout de quelques années au top 50 du
classement international de boxe
féminine et je suis numéro 5
et là évidemment je ne rêve que d'une
chose c'est d'être championne du monde
les entraînements sont intenses
quotidien je me souviens
particulièrement de ses entraînements du
soir 20h 22h dans ma salle à strasbourg
une vraie salle de boxe avec ses sacs
rouges en cuir tanné par les milliers de
coups cette odeur caractéristique que je
reconnaîtrais parmi 1000 cette odeur du
mélange de sueur du mélange de poussière
de camphre dont on s'enduit les muscles
et puis mon coach mon coach andré
infatigable qui nous dirigeait d'une
main de fer dans un gant de fer
on n'avait pas d'autre possibilité que
d'être
hyper performant dans une maîtrise
parfaite
la puissance l'engagement total un jour
pendant cet entraînement il ya le
téléphone qui nous interrompt mon coach
décroche conversation en anglais c'est
le signe que c'est probablement un
promoteur qui nous propose un combat il
me regarde je sais que c'est pour moi je
commence à sentir l'excitation qui monte
c'est un championnat du monde
il m'explique la numéro 1 devait
rencontrer la numéro 2 qui vient de
déclarer forfait pour blessure ils ont
appelé la numéro 3 qui est pas
disponible et l'admirent au 4 10 c'est
trop court alors j'ai dit pourquoi c'est
trop court c'est quand
parce que normalement chanter à du monde
ces six mois de préparation c'est dire
en deçà se prépare longuement unis c'est
samedi prochain
d'accord et là je suis comme quand on
est au bord du plongeoir avec ce mélange
de d'envié de vertige à la fois je me
dis j'ai envie de forcer le destin
je vais prendre le risque ou plutôt je
vais prendre ma chance
et là je m'envole vers copenhague pour
disputer ce combat qui va s'avérer
difficile
cinq premières rondes je décide de me
mettre en mode attaque quand j'avance
sur elle je la lâche pas je lui fais une
pression d'enfer j'arrête pas 50 sellami
la moitié du combat et là je commence un
peu à fléchir j'ai pas j'ai pas
l'entraînement à la hauteur
6e rang je me dis faut que je mette en
mode défensif je recule il se trouve
qu'elle n'attaque pas donc c'est un
rendu plutôt cool septième ronde
je reprends la main parce que je me dis
je tiendrai pas jusqu'au 10e et l'âge
accélère mais un cran au dessus comme
pour lui dire ça c'est mon nouveau
rythme de croisière en réalité je puise
dans mes dernières réserves
je donne tout ce que j'ai et elle craque
elle abandonne au septième rang et je
suis championne du monde c'est mon
premier titre
tu veux conforte dans ce processus de
d'engagement ce processus d'engagement
c'est la première clé que je veux
partager avec vous c'est une clé
extrêmement important dans tous les
sports l'engagement il va être physique
l'engagement c'est l'intensité c'est la
puissance l'engagement il va aussi être
moral c'est l'audace l'audace de croire
que je peux y aller quand les autres ne
vont pas assez l'audace d'investir toute
son énergie à un moment donné bien
précis et alors forte de ce succès
j'ambitionne d'aller plus loin je veux
réunir toutes les couronnes de toutes
les box différentes
je veux être championne du monde en boxe
thaï thaïlandaise en kick boxing boxe
française en boxe anglaise
quelques années après deux trois ans
j'ai atteint cet objectif je réunis ses
cinq couronnes et j'atteins donc ce
sommet qui clôturait par ce combat que
vous venez de voir et donc je jette
finalement j'ai atteint ce que je
voulais je sens que je me suis prouvé ce
que j'avais à me prouver
et bizarrement fin c'est même pas
bizarre mais ma motivation décline je
sens que j'ai plus envie de monter sur
le ring j'ai plus envie d'aller me
battre contre une fille je me dis à quoi
bon j'ai aussi envie d'avoir une vie
normale de me lever le matin d'aller au
boulot j'ai surtout envie de montrer que
je ne suis pas qu une boxeuse une
boxeuse qui est dans l'inconscient
collectif brille plus par sa force
brutale que par sa finesse par sa
capacité d'analysé j'ai très envie de
montrer ça r j'aime m'engager dans une
carrière professionnelle normale avec
toujours cette clé d'engagement qui
m'habite
je vais être commercial acheteuse
directrice des achats
je vais directrice d'une structure et je
vais directrice enfin j'ai fondé ma
propre entreprise
finalement c'est un parcours qui paraît
très performant on va dire une belle
reconversion
sauf que de l'intérieur je suis en
souffrance et ça quasiment depuis le
début je suis en souffrance parce que
tout me semble être difficile à
surmonter
je suis épuisé malgré ça je continue
chez en mode boxeuse jeu il faut que je
continue je surmonte les autres
tiens j'ai du mal à me lever le matin
tout devient pesant je reste à fond
malgré tout et un moment donné ce qui
devait arriver arriva
je m'effondre ans et je m'effondre comme
la russe sauf que j'atterris pas sur un
ring j'atterris à l'hôpital je suis
paralysé des deux jambes complètement
paralysé j'arrive à l'hôpital on fait
plein d'examens on dit tout va bien sauf
que votre mois les temps l'inflammation
total probablement que vous ne
remarcherait plus jamais comme avant
et là la firme r elle m'amène dans ma
chaise roulante dans ma chambre
elle me laisse sur le lit elle repart et
la chaise je suis sur mon lit mais comme
une naufragés sur une île déserte je
peux pas accéder à mes affaires qui sont
à 3 mètres mon téléphone et là je peux
pas les toilettes et je sens profond
désarroi qui va m'envahir je suis ko
je suis ko de tout mon être je suis ko
de toute mon âme et à ce moment-là je me
dis mais comment c'est possible de
passer de cet ultra performance à cet
état de défaillances j'étais championne
du monde quand même
je réfléchis j'écris beaucoup et
abandonner je comprends que il m'a
manqué un ingrédient essentiel qui
pourtant était bien présent en boxe
implicitement peut-être cd coûte de ma
vulnérabilité en boxe etc ou deux de ma
venir habiter c'est presque
intrinsèquement liés à la pratique dans
tous les clubs du monde
on l'apprend à monter sa garde protège
ton visage protège ton fois dans ce
monde professionnel c'était beaucoup
plus imperceptible c'est plus facile de
prendre une droite pour monter sa garde
et pourtant mon corps me le disait
qu'ils étaient malmenés je l'avais
négliger parce que c'était plus mon
instrument de travail mais j'avais eu
des messages des signes cette fatigue
ce cet épuisement si j'avais dessine
aussi que j'avais jamais avant des
migraines des maux de dos tout ça on
peut se dire bon finalement c'est pas si
grave
t'as plus 20 ans mais sauf que ces
signes il était déjà précurseur
précurseur d'un système où je demandais
j'étais à fond je m'en d un niveau
d'énergie qui étaient ici et je ne ne
renouvelait pas mon énergie qui étaient
en bas j'assurais pas la régénération de
cette énergie
c'est un peu comme dans un bocal avec un
poisson quand on ne change pas l'eau
elle se trouble et le poids sont ils au
ralenti jusqu'à s'asphyxier même alors
sur mon lit d'hôpital bas j'ai écouté
les signes de ma vulnérabilité là mon
corps et me criait que je ne peux plus
avancer comme ça ils m'ont a coupé les
jambes
alors j'ai avancé autrement je me suis
documenté je me suis formé pour
comprendre quelles étaient les clés de
ma vitalité et la deuxième clé que je
souhaite partager avec vous c'est cette
clé de la régénération savoir régénérer
ses ressources en ça va s'appuyer sur
trois piliers vous voyez la première clé
la deuxième clé c'est la régénération
qui s'appuie sur trois piliers avec le
premier qui est le repos ça paraît
simple
l'alimentation le deuxième et troisième
pilier
c'est le mouvement le repos à partir de
ce moment là j'ai compris que je devais
m'octroyer du repos déjà c'est arrêter
de croire qu'on peut être à fond tout le
temps je peux pas faire un championnat
du monde tous les jours je peux me
surinvestir je peux me dépasser mais ça
doit être limitée dans le temps
le repos c'est aussi un repos mental cbc
cette charge nerveuse nous accapare sans
arrêt marcher dans la nature ccc méditer
aussi c'est pas regarder une série sur
une table est ce que ça c'est pas du
repos c'est encore une stimulation
le repos c'est aussi savoir se connecter
à des joies simples dans l'asthme dans
l'instantanéité dans treize ans quand
j'étais en chaise roulante
j'avais la taille que j'avais quand
j'avais 6 7 ans en fait je me retourne
je me retrouvais un niveau de vision qui
était se dit que j'ai dit que j'avais
quand j'étais enfant et je me souviens
un moment donné je me laver les mains
donc c'était à ce niveau là et j'ai vu
un plaisir immense à jouer avec l'eau
comme je pouvais le faire quand j'étais
petit à laisser couler l'eau a joué avec
le savon à voir ces bulles qui se former
et ça c'était un vrai plaisir intense
qui m'a pas seulement reposer mais qui
m'a vraiment régénérer le deuxième
pilier après le repos l'alimentation
c'est comme votre voiture on mais pas
n'importe quoi dans son réservoir
j'ai engagé pas mal de réformes au
niveau alimentaire notamment ne pas
manger trop de dénaturer ne pas manger
transformer d'aller au plus aux produits
les plus les plus simples et évidemment
le mouvement parce que dans cette
période intense mais j'avais plus de
temps de faire du sport
aujourd'hui le mouvement fait partie
intégrante de mon activité c'est aussi
important de faire une séance de sport
que d'aller voir un client la
performance véritable ne peut pas se
faire sans régénération cette
régénération il doit être à la hauteur
de l'ambition que vous avez en termes de
performances en donc soyez vraiment
hyper attentif
ces signaux précurseurs de votre corps
pour mettre le paquet sur votre
régénération et des signaux du corps
mais il ya aussi les signaux du coeur et
là encore j'ai pas entendu un signal du
coeur c'est quand ma motivation commencé
à décliner
elle a commencé assez vite à décliner
dans cette nouvelle vie professionnelle
est en fait si je regarde bien je me dis
ce n'était pas la bonne motivation
je voulais montrer que je n'étais pas
qu'une box c'est une motivation qui
s'appuyait sur le
le regard approbateur des autres sur un
référencement extérieur la troisième clé
c'est que la performance ne peut être
véritable que si la motivation est auto
référence et c'est à dire si elle part
de ce qui est important pour vous de vos
propres valeurs et quand j'étais boxeuse
j'avais une vraie motivation to
référencés puisque je voulais sortir de
cette posture d'enfermement de filles
fragiles qu'ils n'osaient pas qu'ils qui
se pensaient jamais assez bonne pour moi
c'était un handicap au quotidien
donc chaque combat que je faisais
j'avais j'avais cette motivation c'était
comme un phare qui me permettait en plus
de mener mes actions avec facilité c'est
ça al'avantage kanté actions sont annie
avec la motivation
et vous quel est votre niveau dans vie
quel est votre com est-ce que vous
sentez cette envie est ce que votre
motivation et auto référence et je vous
invite aussi à aligner vos actions avec
cette motivation pour que vos actions se
fasse sans effort après ce chaos que je
me suis infligé à moi-même ko au sens
littéral noked out une frappe qui m'a
mis hors de moi je suis revenu à moi
finalement en appliquant ces trois clés
en appliquant je me suis reconstruite je
me suis remise sur pied par un
engagement dans la rééducation
évidemment j'ai fait un boulot de fou en
rééducation par l'audace de croire que
si je remarche avait un jour bien sûr
que si par la régénération
tout ce programme sept changements
d'hygiène que j'ai mis en place et bien
sûr par une motivation alignés c'est
drôle parce que j'ai retrouvé les
carnets dans lequel j'écrivais et parmi
mes notamment donné j'avais un jeu
j'écrivais ce qui était important pour
moi et j'ai vu j'ai écrit je veux mettre
les gens au mouvement pour contribuer à
une société juste et harmonieuse
alors ça peut paraître très
les idéalistes mais c'est vraiment ce
que je ressentais quand je relis ça ça
s'impose toujours à moi et aujourd'hui
ce que je fais ça reste quelque chose
qui me guide
j'essaye vraiment d'aligner toutes mes
actions par rapport à 7 à cette
motivation
ce qui est important c'est que ces trois
c sont indissociables si on applique que
la première que l'engagement en mode
warriors même pas mal ça va mieux la
performance mais la performance à court
terme je rencontre un des salariés des
managers même des chefs d'entreprises
qui peuvent lui imposer à leur équipe
alors que l'ensemble des trois clefs va
vraiment conduire à la performance
véritable quand je vous disais 4-2 bout
là devant vous c'était ma plus bande la
plus belle victoire aujourd'hui je
continue à piquer ses clés dès que j'ai
un petit signe de mon corps je
questionne ses clés d'ailleurs quand
j'ai préparé cette conférence il ya une
dizaine de jours j'étais un peu en mode
dépassement fatigué parce que j'avais
pas mesuré que ça me prend d'autant plus
mon boulot etc
je me suis dit mais je suis pas
cohérentes là je vais venir leur
raconter quelque chose est en fait je la
petite pas moi même c'est bon je me pose
et se questionnent auquel engagement
d'accord mais là dans une minute trente
cfta sera fini c'est limité dans le
temps donc c'est ok ma motivation c'est
complètement ok je suis dans dans une
cette logique de transmission c'est
quelque chose qui est important pour moi
et régénération bas parce que j'ai un
niveau d'exigence important là dans
cette période là bas je vais mettre le
paquet sur la régénération
je vous invite à suivre ce chemin de
l'engagement intense au plus proche de
vous c'est ce qui vous permettra de vous
offrir vos plus belles victoires
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]